might suffer the horrors that
six-year-old wadia did in Illinois the
other thing you have to do also is shed
crocodile tears so here's Rashida
herself and anti-Semitism makes us all
less safe and worried that your own
child might suffer the horrors that
six-year-old W did in
aloi I can't believe I have to say this
but Palestinian people are not
disposable
we are human
beings just like anyone else my Cy my
grandmother like all
Palestinians just wants to live her life
with freedom and human dignity we all
deserve speaking up to save lives Mr
chair no matter faith no matter
ethnicity should not be controversial in
this chamber the cries of the
Palestinian and CH Palestinian and
Israeli Children sound no different to
me why what I don't understand is why
the cries of Palestinians sound
different to you
all we cannot lose our shared Humanity
Mr
chair the shared Humanity where is the
shared Humanity I mean it's
just oh oh
thank you it's just cuz Rashida she
loves everybody you know what I mean
it's those white people that hate every
like they ate everybody and and Rashid
is a good woman
and you get extra guacamole today that
was good that was good anyway her
crocodile tears The Psychotic screaming
of those other two and a couple of their
other friends it did not work because
yes she was censured here is new house
Majority Leader Mike Johnson officially
announcing that it has passed on this
vote the yays are
234 and the Nays are 188 with four
answering present the resolution is
[Music]
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table for okay
so yes it happened she will be removed
from a couple of her positions which
that is good this person should be
ignored and and if you are a Democrat if
there are any Democrats watching this if
you are a Democrat you should not want
these people in your party the inmates
are running the Asylum and there might
be a way to restore a decent Democrat
Party right there might be a way to
revert the Democrat Party back to a JFK
type Democrat Party or even a even a hey
I don't know maybe a Bill Clinton
Democrat type party uh it's a damn shame
that they got rid of Robert F Kennedy
who's now an independent because he saw
that the whole that the writing was on
the wall and the inmates were running
the Asylum and all that stuff there
might be a way to make it so that the
Democrats aren't completely psychotic
and racist and want to destroy the
United States of America but if there is
it's on you guys the Democrats because I
ain't no Democrat it's on you guys to
figure out what you are going to do with
these people because trust me this is
not about the Jews and it ain't about
Israel what this is about ultimately is
destroying the United States of America
and the they are in the house right the
Killer is calling from upstairs and his
name is Rashida
Talib